with the yankees um losing the way that
they have and the pure mediocrity of the
of the team on the field sometimes i
will uh see my twitter feed
and sometimes i'll get it on my text and
it's the same all caps
very angry man and i'm like okay let's
get him on here together
you and i are gonna work this out nick
deturo here on the rich eisen show
die hard yankee fan and uh somebody
who's
career work i loved an nypd blue and
everything else you do good to see you
nick you too buddy
i wish it was under better circumstances
no well you know what we're here though
i know we're here
uh i know what's wrong with the team
what do you think that's wrong with the
team
i think the team is just uh they're
built wrong
i think they you know it's been heading
that way since 18
17 i thought we had some great mojo we
had greg bird a left-handed hitter we
had d.d gregorius
we even had the god todd father we had
some chemistry
and then we made this bad trade for
stanton which i think is the beginning
of
everything that went wrong the balance
of the team has been out of whack
for a couple of years now i don't know
why they don't see it we
see it i see it you see it what's the
problem
what's the problem we haven't won a
championship since 09 we've basically
had one championship in 20 years
people like be quiet you're spoiled not
spoiled
not spoiled i became a yankee fan in 73
when they sucked
they won in 77 78 all right i had a run
in the 90s
we had droughts 18 years from 78 to 96
right yeah
now we had one token championship the
red sox have kicked our ass
oh four oh seven thirteen eighteen
the rays are kicking our butt other
teams the astros
i mean come on we've become very content
with being like somewhat relevant we're
a right-handed
one-note team that is a that is that is
a fact and wouldn't that be incredible
chris
brockman if uh mr tutturo is spot on
here
that uh the stanton trade is what began
to unravel
or make it even more one dimensional
and my my friend across the aisle chris
brockman
and the rest of new england the only
word for it was bitching up a storm
complaining that jeter handed the
yankees
a gift wrap in stanton
yeah and it was you were you were saying
it was jeter was doing a favor to his
old team
yeah man it reeked of kevin mchale doing
doc rivers a favor
sending kevin garnett to the celtics you
know and then the championship incurred
it just seemed like it was hey you take
this awesome guy who hits 50 home runs
and is an mvp but he has fallen off a
cliff well i don't know when he cooks
with gas though
i mean which he'll he'll spike and do it
you know and then
invariably he'll get hurt or then uh you
know and then
play happens and he doesn't play for for
a week or what have you
but you don't know a guy till you know
him you know like you don't know a woman
till you live with her
you might fall in love and then you live
with the woman and you go oh my god
it's a nightmare you know what i mean
you got to look at somebody day to day
you got to watch them
all the time to know what they are and i
never saw this guy
he's sexy he hits the ball further than
anybody
yeah he's powerful but there's a flip
side to that
and the flip side isn't good he's not
consistent
he's a strikeout waiting to happen when
he's good he's good but
you know you can't you can't count on
him you can't really just say
hey this guy is going to fight he's
going to get his bat on the ball
he's going to you know he's a good fit i
mean if we would have got the other guy
yelich
you know judah really stuck it to us and
that contract
i mean i hate to say that jeter of all
people said here take him of course
take him yelidge was out there he gave
yellage away
yelledge would have been perfect for
this team could you imagine his team
with yellage and they had dede
and they could have went out this
offseason and got i was talking about
this yesterday with jeff nelson
schwarber was out there schwarber for no
money
who would have been a dynamite hitter a
great dh that's the short porch there
a monster but then he's also another one
of those guys though
i understand but you know nick deturo
here in the rich eisen show and i was
saying the other day
and because you know i know you you're a
die-hard yankee fan but you love the
sport you see all the
you see you see all the games you see as
much as you can
uh just building a team i would now
build a team
where it's contact that's all you got to
do you have to put the ball
in play if you strike out it is
a walk of shame to come back to my
dugout and look at me
right you know and the rest of the team
like i want i want people who are going
to put the ball
in play i mean a perfect example you
know
are was what the red sox did i think the
red sox put a handful of runs on the
yankees this weekend didn't even get the
ball out of the infield but they
made yeah make kind of contact and they
made the yankees
make plays i mean the rays the rays are
just a
king of making contact uh you know
obviously a rose arena strikes out a lot
but there are
everybody has one or two players these
days that strike out a lot but
you've got to put the ball and play the
san francisco giants of 50 wins
i don't even know who's on that team but
but if they who's on that team
i don't know but they won 50 games
no but no that's the posies
from the old winning team but other than
that i couldn't tell you who's on that
team
look at the padres yeah the a's
the a's are a fun team i was giving them
love and they were writing articles oh
they're giving
tutorials giving the a's love and these
she's complimenting uh you know melvin
and i go yeah they're fun to watch
this team i want to love them i want to
fall in love i can't fall in love with
them
you know i mean i'm trying i'm really
trying to a bad watch
i've seen bad yankee teams that were fun
to watch they were fun they had some
romance in them they had something
they had somebody on the team i really
liked you know i still love judge i mean
i like lemayo
even though he's not having a great year
but this team is
is is all wrong they got to start over
yeah
there's your tweet that's it i to turn
it off eight two i cannot watch until
heads roll so you do know that the red
sox added another run right
19. yes i did yeah i mean i'll say that
i'm never going back
but i'm a sick person that way i'm like
i'm done and my daughter's like didn't
you say you were done i said
yeah i know what i say is one thing how
i feel is another
okay that's a line from the honeymoon
what i said about morton is one thing
how i feel about him is another
and that's true in life you know a lot
of times you might say i hate you i hate
your guts
but me deep down you know i love her i
still love you you know what i mean but
but you you're just angry you're upset
anger it's a moment yeah listen i want
them to win i want them to do it and
these guys on tour
oh you're a front runner you're fair
weather up yours i'm a front runner
i'm a true fan through thick and thick i
just call it the way it is
and i say it in a harsh way now cause
i'm frustrated that's all
i just want to see them play better even
if they don't win
you know lose with dignity go down
fighting see that's the whole thing too
nick deturo here on the rich eisen show
it's just
i i don't know what it is like i and
this is a new york thing do you remember
kevin mcreynolds used to play for the
mets
you remember him right tj right and and
he didn't have a pulse
he never met fans would go crazy you
know and and
those people don't do well in new york
no matter i i want to see someone like
o'neill take a bat
to a gatorade you know can yeah and like
what what you know
um brett gardner did the savages in the
box from two years ago like there
doesn't seem to be any sort of
anger about what's going on like no
personality on this team you see the red
sox
throwing the guy through the they're
wheeling the guys for the dugout the
padres have the big
thing a big thing around their neck come
on we need somebody with some
personality
who who is this team that's what i mean
who's what are they who are they
i mean i'm not in the dugout if they put
me as a bad honorary bat boy or
something like that maybe i could do
something
i'd love to see that that would be
something i know a woman wrote a letter
in 1960
she's getting that that should be me i
should get that shot for everything i've
done i was almost a bad boy in 77 long
story
and it didn't work out what do you mean
well there was a kid in my school he was
a bad boy
san randria he was a yankee batboy 77
like when when
reggie was there listen to this story i
was at saint agnes cathedral
and everybody said i didn't know the kid
he was from rosedale
and he was the yankee bay he didn't even
care that he had the job
what yes he just to me it didn't seem
like he appreciated it
he was probably born into it so anyway
they said
sir andrea's looking for and everybody
said you gotta go get this guy
nick deturo so i tracked the guy down i
said hey
i heard that do you understand that i'm
i'm interested i said you know
he goes i would i would recommend you
but they want a black kid
i said what i sent them the wrong color
i was like just tell them i'm mixed
anything whatever i should have did my
dna
so that that would and the kid that got
the job he didn't even care they fired
him whatever
i was dying i saw on my third base i was
like that should be me
i should be on the field i should have
that job you know
so i missed out you know i noticed this
girl wants to be a bad boy from the 60s
but i'm like
i'm available you know what i mean i
think you could change the side nick
i think i could help it couldn't hurt it
couldn't hurt you know what i mean
a little mojo what do they got to lose
what do they got to lose
brian cashman boone all these guys i'm
out there that's all i put it out there
but
you know maybe i'm not i'm too too wild
for them or something i don't know what
the problem is
i think that might be it yeah you'd have
more personality than anyone on the team
right now
that's true that's true and that's sad
what do you think of all the
check and are you concerned that coal is
not going to be the same now because the
the spot attack's gone i don't know how
that with all the checking of the
pictures and stuff i'm a little
concerned
i think they should have did it in the
middle of the season and i don't know
what they were doing and i don't
understand this whole
sticky thing and i don't know to what
degree you know and it's
it's sort of stupid that they're doing
it now you know maybe these guys were
abusing it
i don't know how bad it was but i am a
little concerned i mean
they should have did it in the beginning
of the year not the middle of the year
mlb they they're always trying to be you
know slick they always try to do things
but
yeah worry about the guys calling
strikes they can't even call a strike
these days have you seen the strike zone
it's i watched actually an oriole blue
jay game yesterday jim palmer nearly
wherever he was calling the game i don't
know if i i doubt he was in buffalo
where the blue jays are playing right
now
i doubt if if he was um he's probably in
his house
he was ready to jump out and hit like
there were two balls that were
two two strikes that were called balls i
mean obviously what happened to the
yankees and the last time they played
the red sox and yankee stadium and
sunday night baseball
was terrible i don't know i i you know
it
it it's obviously a more dif it's a the
job's more difficult to do
certainly when they're now actually they
they uh they threw out uh a pitcher for
the first time
yes you see that yeah yeah the mariners
right
they said it was rosin yeah and then
rossignol hector santiago was rosin in
his glow yeah he said
i only used rosin i had it on the inside
of my glove because it was really hot
and i didn't want the sweat dripping off
my hand
and how about girardi using it against
yours in the middle of an inning yeah
well jerrod is a little tightly wound
yeah that's one way of putting it you
don't want to fight that dude
kick-ass but scherzer though is also
someone you don't want to mess with sure
they don't scare me
girardi's a killer he's a killer
that guy is tightly wound yeah oh who
what with his binder he's right now
his binder doesn't make him any more
relaxed he needs a good
massage somebody needs to rub his neck
because he's like this jody you know i
threw out a pitch to him in the spring
training 96
okay i sat with george steinberg i did
all these commercials for espn
their legendary comment was a guy
playing abe lincoln and me revitalizing
baseball
and i was they're great commercials it
was like the funniest crap espn ever did
and you got to find it somewhere
okay it's me on the road and anyway i
was in tampa they opened up the
legends field and um they let me throw
out a pitch uh
i think i threw like a cutter or
something cohn was like wow and girardi
caught the ball i didn't know who joe
girardi was
it was a nice pitch i didn't i didn't
blow it you know and then i sat with
george i was actually i was on you know
the tv show and i'm sitting with
steinbrenner
it was amazing he had a windbreaker on
he said you know we got big things about
this kid jeter nick
and i was like yeah yeah i've heard
about them i was like what an amazing
day what an amazing four days of
shooting like these
baseball commercials and then my agent
at the time marty lee sack funny guy he
wanted me to get bats you know marty
sure he's a diary
crazy he calls me every what are we
gonna do baby
what are we gonna do honey hello marty
what do you
see something go out there and see
something i go marty
i am saying stuff every day does he not
see you
no he doesn't watch stuff he he's like
well what happened
what do you mean what happened are you
not watching the game
did you not watch my twitter you know
he's hilarious so he was like did you
get me the bed
did you get a bed i got the bat don't
call me three o'clock in the morning to
find out if i got you to the bat
so steinberg gave you a bet and
everything like that some of the guys
that did commercials with barry locke
and darren dalton they all gave me bats
you know
wade wade chicken boggs before i did one
because
when they won in 96 they brought me on
the field
you were probably there that night rich
and um somehow i got into the clubhouse
and i was doing interviews with some
westchester station i had no voice they
were like do interviews
and i was interviewing like the yankee
players and uh it was hysterical that
was in 96. well girardi hit that triple
to wrap that
wrap the series up yeah yankees winning
four in a row against the
some of the big pitch we got tom glavin
calling into the show
in a couple days i think we'll we'll
probably neglect to bring this up to him
but
you know i mean that was awful maddox if
i'm not mistaken
i'm sure maddox in game six you're
already at a triple yeah that
that put the thing in the ice yeah
and the it was all iced after that oh
that was girardi's moment
i mean that place was rocking that night
rocking i mean they
they lost the first two they won the
next three i stayed till saturday night
uh we were shooting exteriors
it was a week be a week that i'll never
forget what
i mean the other day you know what
killed me when a guy tagged up
on a fly ball the first i said this luke
voight oh it was devers who came home
yeah on a fly ball i said i i've had it
this is it
it doesn't get any worse than i hate to
tell you man this is it's a five-alarm
fire right now for the yankees there's
no question in my mind
that they're a team that strikes out way
too much hits into way too many double
plays doesn't put the ball into play
nearly enough
and i don't know how that's going to
turn around unless the entire team has
an epiphany
and can start actually hitting can you
know they don't have anybody from the
left side
nobody they don't have anybody after
cole i mean
you know montgomery and tyonne and
whatever i don't want to hear i mean
no i'm saying like they don't like you
know yankees used to be two three four
deep they don't have
those guys anymore to not i never
thought i'd be wondering where tanaka is
uh you know and and then when it all
comes down to it i'll be very honest
with you
you know you mentioned steinbrenner's
name and and he was the bane of
of my world when mattingly who's on
tomorrow's show
i mean don what what what steinbrenner
did to mattingly
i wanted him out and then when don when
when steinbrenner went away is when the
yankees finally were able to just turn
to stick michael and bob watson and let
them do their thing
right and cashmere was learning at their
side and that's when the yankees with
tory put it all together for all those
years
and for me you know i'm
i i never thought i would say this they
need somebody like steinbrenner they
come back and kick somebody's ass
they do that you know not every team
needs that but uh
like what happened this weekend
would be of you know right now it's just
like okay we'll see what happens tonight
because we'll see somebody's exit
velocity will take care of it
and the spin rate will get to where it
needs to be right and that's the way it
sort of seems to be right i know
it's like they they've they've accepted
being a mediocre baseball team
and that you know this is the team but
we believe in them and i'm like it's not
working man
it's not and it's not going to change
you know no miracles are going to happen
i realize it now i'm not going to get
excited i don't get they try to suck me
in
and try to get me up in the air because
they're always going to let me down so
i'm not buying it no more
the rest of the season are you serious
are you not watching i'll be watching
i'll be watching
i say i'm not watching but don't believe
that that's you know that's that's
that's not really true nick tuturo uh
here
uh in studio to wrap up the show what's
that shirt you're wearing
that's that's like a hawaiian shirt it's
just it's the sandlot shirt
so since you like one i'm gonna i'm
gonna try i mean it's like a giant shirt
where it looks like hot dogs right yeah
and
and smalls yeah pointing a call in a
shot
right yeah judge was wearing it and
that's how i then i researched
it and you know because i watch fashion
i'm a fashion guy okay
certain kinds of fashion yeah vintage
whatever okay i have a good eye
so uh it's my hobby so i saw the shirt
and i said yeah i gotta get it i gotta
get it so you know like i become
obsessed with things and so
every time i put it on people love it
okay
it's a choice what are you a lodge i'm a
large oh yeah yeah cause you're in good
shape better shape than me i've never
known about that no you are you know i'm
trying
i'm trying to watch myself i'm trying to
watch myself yeah i could see the way
you're getting me you're my wife's age
i'm 52. i know i
just said my god you're 52. um how old
are you
59. trying to make it to 60. you're
gonna
stop watching the yankees if you're like
60. no no it's bad other than my
grandson coming in he's been saving me
18 months old you got to see this kid
swing it's really a phenom i have to
send you a video of him
santino he's he's got somebody who's
17 months right 16 months my kid's got
an amazing golf swing already yeah he's
got the big high finish the little boy
just like finishes high nice and high
did you teach him obsessed well all we
do is watch golf and baseball
right he's obsessed and he's picked it
up he's picked it up all he wants to do
is hit balls in the backyard yeah and
his mother's a uh big braves fan so he
watches
albies and he watches acuna and he
watches freeman so he was watching a
better team
yeah they got better and they got they
got better everything yeah
now that's a baseball team they strike
out a lot the braves yeah yeah
that's right but they stay but they put
the ball in play and they hit it out of
the yard and they got young players that
go out of their skulls right now they
can't pitch that's
that's kind of their problem right now
yeah they got max freight over there kid
from our neighborhood yeah he's hurt
though
oh my gosh um so uh
while you're all worked up uh give me
your give me your best caruso story
come on now david caruso you're obsessed
with caruso right
are you kidding who isn't obsessed with
him
i love caruso i really do i mean uh
i um i took him into a pitch one time
he wrote this show called good cop bad
cop he wrote it
he wrote it okay yeah because he had
seen i did a pilot one year for the wb
and
he came to the taping and he was moved
we should have got picked up whatever we
got
some girl with big breasts got picked up
over us
it's still very sore with me because
this was a great show i did it was
called
nick it didn't have a great title you
need a good title
like what i'm trying to sell now has a
good title i have a new show called band
of idiots
that's a good title that's a great title
and the knicks show was
not a good type but it was a really like
a modern day all in the family and
caruso
you know came to the uh the taping and
he was moved he was moved you know with
the red hair he was like nick you really
you surprised me he was like you know
he always used to compliment me because
yeah at the beginning i wasn't sure when
i first started with him i'd be like
i only had a line here a line there be
like dave am i okay he's like
you're beautiful beautiful don't let
anybody mess with you
i said what don't let anybody mess with
you
you know so we went and did a pitch at
like uta and
and uh i had you know i started knowing
how to do these pictures you know and it
was his show he wrote it
so i went in the room and i went wild on
the agent i was like what do you bring
to the table
i brought caruso i brought the script i
went wild on him and these guys
and he was like loving it loving it the
agent was like you better back down i
said don't tell me to back down
i said you're not bringing you know
nothing to the table
and so caruso goes who would have
thought that tutorial was the bad guy
you know he loved it that i went out on
a limb for him yeah
and and i and he just sat back you know
and he was like man you
you are one piece of work you know and
uh but then you know
the guy got on the csi and it was like
hey dave you know
can you throw me a bone or whatever i
was like yeah i called him up and i go
they're doing a spin-off dave
you know oh they are going what do you
mean they are come on
you know so i loved caruso i still love
him but you know he was
caruso was for caruso he's he's he told
me a funny story about de niro
that de niro reamed him on mad dog and
glory
he said he didn't like me i said why
because he probably tried to step on
you know de niro bob's told her i mean
you're not going to push a guy like that
around
that ain't going to happen so he's like
he took him in the corner and he goes
you are f in this movie you are so over
the top
says what deniro says to me i'm telling
caruso that he put him in the corner
but caruso's really good in the movie
he's like really good
in mad dog i mean he played a great cop
yeah i was watching an old caruso movie
the other night china girl and he's good
in it
him and james russo um i i love the guy
we had great chemistry together
we had this other movie that we were
gonna do that he found yeah
and it never got made but it was like a
dark comedy because me and him
i still think could be fireworks i don't
know what it is i'm dog he's got red
hair
we're both from queens maybe that's it
he's from queens i don't know
he's a malloy guy you know malloy our
[ __ ]
when we had our show open for uh for the
super bowl in miami did it come out
not him put it up on the screen it was
this that's me that's you that's me
that's pretty good rich that's me did
you imitate him
damn strange it was great it was a lot
oh my gosh it was funny
you know we were still with directv and
att and the the group that
puts these opens together says we have
two choices for your open
that we've come up with for the super
bowl in miami right the first one
is a version of csi miami where you play
caruso and i just stopped him right
there i'm like i don't care what your
other
idea is that's the one we're doing i'm
doing it can you give me a line
and we got nic look look at me right
there but i want to hear one line one of
the lines
like uh what was jeez i forget now
um you know no no i
this is going into overtime something
like that like
wow well we obviously didn't have the we
couldn't afford the who music
yeah we got rex lin to do his role too
the whole thing man he didn't make eye
contact in that show much
right he never really looked at the
other guy no
but his signature maneuver though
it's brilliant his signature maneuver
was to deliver the line so many people
used to would take off the glasses and
deliver the line
he would put the glasses on and to
deliver the line
that was the next level caruso it is
maneuver
it's an exaggerated career show but i
think it's i think it's brilliant you
know he wanted to be steve mcqueen
that's the problem but there's only one
steve mcqueen that's right the queen's
pretty cool
caruso's cool too is pretty cool she's
pretty cool you know we used to go to
lunch together hang out together in his
trailer
taught me how to smoke cigars he's like
what's the matter with the rest of these
guys here nick they're not like you
he's like yeah they're not but you know
i love you dave you know
just take it easy i go don't quit the
show i pleaded with him
i go that's a mistake dave you don't you
don't throw a character like one of the
great
yeah and boccico the whole bit steve
bochko was behind them to a you know to
a point
you know you didn't see james gandolfini
get rid of tony soprano in one year yeah
he was lucky he got another big show out
oh
my gosh oh my god something when
somebody's looking out for him
yeah because when you throw that away
you you're not never going to get
another shot like that
exactly so he was a very lucky man
should count his blessings i don't have
that kind of look
but what are you going to do that's
caruso nick taturo here on the rich
island show thanks for coming on
my pleasure don't forget to plug white
clothes game oh yeah
uh we've got about a minute and a half
to go i'm sorry we went down the caruso
i know you loved it white claw gabe
who's like the king of tick tock
dropping f-bombs and whatever i i was
introduced to his work yes
uh yesterday your son is the is
producing him is the producer of him
i'm sort of his like you know confidant
uh you know he runs by he runs he runs
by his uh
takes yeah he has to get all his
material approved by my son
uh he's a very very funny man probably
the funniest man on social media
i knew he was funny for like 20 years
but i just didn't know how to get him
there
but my son has kind of put him in the
right platform today it's all about
platforms
you need a platform like i don't have a
real platform that's not true
i have a little platform i come on here
you know twitter but you need a platform
like
but i also don't curse like that i do
curse but not like that
by the way and for people who do know
your platform and your
your your takes on twitter yeah uh and
maybe laughing that you don't curse like
somebody else
it's true you don't curse that that that
i
white claw gave is earmuff uh territory
right there but yeah but these [ __ ]
interesting things it works it's very
funny you can't change what works
it works for this guy for him yes it
works for him some people are like
you're trying to be like white glue i go
i'm trying to be like i know the guy
20-something years
you know my history i made i invented
white clothes
you know i mean i'm not trying to like
call before white cop that's right
and i love the guy i'm a fan i'm still a
fan i'll always be a fan that's the
difference with me and
some other people like that not they
lost being a fan thanks for coming on
nick
my pleasure i really appreciate it hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here